so I know David has been covering the
gruesome details of the journalist who
was killed allegedly killed by Saudi
Arabia Saudi Arabian operatives this
next story is troubling in its own way
connected to that televangelist Pat
Robertson I've covered him quite a bit
he has the salt his sole purpose is to
provide a a quote-unquote spiritual
cover for the barbarity of the
Republican Party that should be his job
description like his title on his show
should not just be televangelists but
should be I provide cover for
Republicans to do whatever they want and
I give religious justification so that
the religious community will never
question the Republican Party so that
they can always benefit from that
community's vote that should be his
title as long as and as that was but I
want you to watch this video as he goes
one step one step further and he
basically makes the case that we as the
United States should not risk a hundred
and ten billion dollar arms deal over
the murder of of journalists Jamal
khashoggi and Wendy I just don't think
you've got a hundred billion dollars
worth of arms sales which is you know
that's one of those things but more than
that we've got to have some Arab allies
we have to have it we cannot alienate a
biggest player in the Middle East whose
bulwark against Iran but can we have
somebody that's killing journalists that
our us residence is the question you
know we've had so many people killed I
mean we had CIA people killed in Lebanon
that people have been taken hostage here
over the years I know it's bad but I
mean we've had all kinds of stuff but
you don't blow up an international
alliance over one person I mean I'm
sorry I mean this is this is next level
this is next level I mean I've seen Pat
Robertson do some pretty disgusting
things and to do those things in the
name of God is just that's his forte
that's his that's what he's made his
millions of
dollars off of his connection to power
his connection to the Republican Party
he would literally do anything to come
it didn't matter that Donald Trump had
all these illicit affairs it didn't
matter that Donald Trump bragged about
all of his sexual improprieties and his
his sexual abuse it didn't matter that
that that the Republican Party has
carried itself in the most barbaric
fashion and they have devolved into
everything opposite of what this guy Pat
Robertson turns around and tells
everyone else they need to be never mind
the fact that they're nothing like Jesus
the fact is is that Pat Robertson
literally tells people every single day
that they need to live like this that
they need to be this they need to be
kind they need to be gracious they need
to be moral they need to be moral right
and then he turns around and provides
cover for the Republican Party that's
his job this is next level because now
not only is he excusing the murders of
this the murder rather of this
journalist but he's also saying that
this one person is not worth it is not
worth it this problem in addition to
that he's ignoring all of the litany of
problems with Saudi Arabia in the first
place it blows me away that the
connection that Saudi Arabia had to 9/11
has always been ignored by the
Republican Party along with some
Democrats but put specifically by the
Republican Party despite the fact that
they used 9/11 they have used it and
it's already done and complete to create
this military state this this police
state the surveillance state and to
crack down on every aspect of our
American liberties and you kill millions
of people across the globe right so it's
one thing not you're protecting Saudi
Arabia and every way imaginable despite
the fact that you're using what Saudi
Arabia does as a means of hurting your
people again like the first story this
is a feature and not a bug this is
exactly what the Republican Party wants
to do alone with a handful of Democrats
who cosign this but right now the
Republicans are in party donald trump is
covering it we'll get into more of the
details of this murder but Donald Trump
is providing cover
for the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and and
Pat Robertson actually said this in an
earlier portion of that clip he said
quote what the president is trying to do
is give the Saudis and out
exactly exactly Pat Robertson but you
see nothing wrong with that you see that
as the correct thing to do to give the
Saudis and now nevermind that they were
directly allegedly directly connected to
the murder of this journalist never mind
that never mind their atrocities in
Yemen that are ongoing I mean if one
person wasn't enough okay let's let's
take that maybe you know he's trying to
present himself as a as a as an
international relations realist okay
he's just gonna be a realist if one
person is not enough surely the tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people who have been brutalized in Yemen
who have died at the hands of Saudi
Arabia aided by the United States surely
that should be enough to Stu to conjure
up the morality that you try to force on
us but it's not you know why because
this is not a mistake in his in his way
of thinking this is not the Republicans
forgetting this is not this is not them
being unknowingly hypocritical this is
them Pat Robertson specifically being
intentionally hypocritical in order to
accomplish their political goals while
using the same morality that they beat
across our head they use that to twist
it for their political ends but
knowingly and willingly and absolutely
enjoy the fact that they can ignore that
morality when it doesn't suit them so to
comment on this is not to comment on his
bigotry but to really point out Pat
Robertson's barbarity that he is a
brutish evil man who uses religion as a
means of justifying his political agenda
I am really thrilled to tell you that
one of today's sponsors is a service
that I personally use myself called
simple habit and you can get a free
trial at simple habit calm slash Pakman
it is really important to take a break
from Twitter to take a break from the
inundation of
politics and media and Trump and all of
the stuff that's going on and a really
great way to take that break and sort of
do a mental reset is with simple habit a
guided meditation app that just won the
2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app perfect for people with
busy lifestyles you just need five
minutes a day
they have morning meditations
meditations for going to sleep
meditations for dealing with headaches
stress meditations for athletes for
fighting procrastination for promoting
creativity they have a huge catalogue of
hundreds and hundreds of meditations for
almost anything you're trying to
accomplish and you can use the app to
track all of your progress they also
have music you can listen to that's
designed specifically to keep you calm
and focused while you're working or
reading go check it out you can try it
free for seven days at simple habit calm
slash Pakman I've put a link underneath
this video